NBC sports golf channel analyst joining
us from the airport in Dublin let me
start with that note it would you rather
have Rickie Fowler's career Shane
Lowery's it's always been a pretty
simple decision for me I'd rather
ashamed Lowery's career at this point I
feel like most every player growing up
dreams about winning the biggest
tournaments and if you grow up in Great
Britain and Ireland or Europe you dream
about the Open Championship and what we
saw this week was magical it was fitting
and when you find a player that
everybody can basically get behind
because he's such a good dude it's
easier route for him and he walks away
with the big prize so I definitely take
a major over a lot of money and a lot of
popularity more impressive what he did
yesterday in those conditions or what he
did on Saturday to put him in a position
where he could basically coast on Sunday
well I think the third round 63 will
probably get the majority of attention
but I think the work that he put in
yesterday I was out there I started out
with us in Johnson's group for about
five or six holes and then I fell back
and covered Fowler started to finish and
that weather was dreadful I mean there
was a double or triple bogey waiting
around every corner the rough was just
so high and it was just an extremely
difficult difficult round to just make a
par and if you look at the last 12
groups that teed off so 24 players not
one player broke par the best player was
was Tony Fino that shot even par so it
tells you that the guys that were
playing the best that are some of the
best players in the world could not go
out there and beat the golf course and
on that particular day it was so tough
yeah I tried to tell people that that I
thought Sunday what he did yesterday was
more impressive than Saturday because
those conditions if you're chasing
somebody with a big lead you're just
hoping the weather is not good because
you're hoping that maybe they run into
some trouble and the way he navigated
that but a lot of this is almost like
Augusta when you play these courses in
Europe nothing prepares you for playing
an you know a course and you know the
Open Championship when you're on these
link style courses you can play in
inclement weather but it's local
knowledge certainly plays a large role
how much do you think that he'll
some of these guys we saw at the top of
the leaderboard well Shane in particular
I mean he didn't seem to be a second by
the weather I mean it's one thing to
prepare for and sort of be gritty and
tough I mean like a like a guy like
Fowler who has proven to play well in
inclement weather oh no to you there now
we'll see if we can I'm waiting for
fritzy to say I wish he had a better
phone line yeah well I was waiting but
Fritsche was trying to track down Noda
yes make love so Rickie Fowler's a good
bad weather player another point for
Rickie Fowler my tweets are coming in
fast and heavy on Rickie vs. chill hours
I know a lot of Rickie fans yes Rick
he's very popular I would rather be
Rickie Fowler than Shane Lowry but I can
identify with Shane Lowry
all right limp notice back with us you
were saying note about okay before we
were rudely interrupted as far as you
know playing in those conditions and you
can't simulate those so he seemed to be
pretty comfortable what is the worst
part about playing in those conditions
Club collection and shop collection I
mean it's a completely different game
you're aimed or not you can't aim for a
lot of hole locations I mean you have to
play away from them you have to play off
slopes you have to take any
considerations line that necessarily
practice or so it's a constant constant
struggle just to just to pull the right
Club and to keep the ball out of the
wind and and visually be able to see a
ball running up from 40 or 50 yards
short of the green those are the players
that handled it the best and it's just
the tough thing to pivot from in terms
of from American golf to link style golf
and not everybody is able to make that
transition but if you grow up with it
like Shane did inclement weather links
golf he went out there and he proved
that he was ready and up for the town
talking ánotá Beghe NBC Sports Golf
Channel analysts good buddy of Tiger
Woods which leads me to Tigers saying it
may be father time had caught up with
him did father time
with him from April and then got him in
July like what did you see or not see
from Tiger this week nota well it was
always going to be a tough week here
this this tournament will private
toughest one to win in terms of his
physical preparation because it's always
cold here I mean a warm day is 65
degrees and anybody that's ever had any
kind of back ailment or surgery knows
that what it's cold your your back is is
doesn't feel good and so I think you saw
that in the opening round I was out
watching him hit balls in the rainy
weather Wednesday prior to the first
round and it was just it was tough
mobility and it could be expected now
that's going to change when you see him
come back in the playoffs where he gets
back to the US it start to get hot and
humid we're going through a heat wave
right now and anybody has any sort of
low back problem like myself that I
struggled with looks forward to the hot
and humid temperatures because your body
moves faster so I think we'll see better
things are in the glass the events of
the year
yeah Nick Faldo said that I think the
first day the opening round where he
said you know this isn't a place where
Tiger he expected Tiger to do well
because if it was 85 90 degrees then you
know he would be loose and he wouldn't
get loose over there and he thought that
that would his back would probably be an
issue when you started when you look at
this year's golf I mean this was Brooks
kept his year how would you how would
you compare this with other great years
that you've been around of or part of
well just just by the numbers and what
he had the ability to do he's one of a
handful of golfers that had a chance to
you know finish in the in the top five
and all four majors through the year
there was that list of like five or six
players long he had a really terrible
cutting week and he's just set a new
standard I think everybody looks towards
the Dustin Johnson's the Rory McIlroy's
and maybe the Justin Rose is to lead the
charge in these big tournaments but it's
been kept Kahoot is kind of elevated
himself and even created some distance
away from even that elite level just by
his approach his demeanor his candor I
mean it's not what we see in the
everybody so measured and what they say
and how they say it but Brooks just
tells you exactly what he thinks and not
always what the other players like to
hear but it certainly gives him it
demonstrates the confidence that he has
in his game and how he has figured out a
winning formula for these big
tournaments I know that Kefka got upset
with JB Holmes his playing partner
taking forever what can you do in a
situation like that when you're you're
supposed to get a certain amount of time
and you have a rules official there who
is supposed to put you on the clock at
least you know this isn't the first time
JB Holmes has taken forever to hit a
shot yeah I mean he's kind of acquired
that reputation and for good reason he
drops anchor out there and meticulous
process you know I would hate for that
to become something that other players
try to do to Brooks to get him off his
game I think Brooks needs to sort of
figure out a way to deal with slow play
sometimes your challenges and
professional golf come from loose wings
or somebody screaming out somebody in
the gallery or a bad break and in this
particular case it's slow play I mean
Rose was a little slow on Saturday which
you might have caused some issue with
Brooks and JB was definitely a little
bit slow yesterday so that and and you
know the governing bodies haven't proven
that they're they're able to enforce the
slow play rules and it's just it's kind
of this one of those things it's it's a
sort of ugly part of our game right now
and JB certainly can get slow I mean
you're not always that way I followed
him on Saturday and he was okay but you
kind of dropped the anchor a little bit
on Sunday but can you say something as a
playing partner like dude let's go hit
it yeah you can but it you know creates
a little animosity or a uncomfortable
feeling you certainly can in players hat
I mean Rory Sabbatini was really
outspoken about and cranked slow play
and even played up literally a hole
ahead above just and it was just kind of
a crazy scenario but that doesn't always
happen in our game and everybody's you
know pretty much gets along and
you know tries to just focus on what
they're doing and how they're doing it
not get sucked into somebody else's
playing speed or whatever but it can
have an adverse effect if you let it get
ya notice safe travels back always
appreciate your time we appreciate it
I think that's Notah Begay for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]